joining us now author of the number one
bestseller the Russia hoax the illicit
scheme to clear Hillary Clinton and
frame Donald Trump Gregg Jarrett and
Florida congressman Matt Gaetz all right
Matt I want to go to you first simple
question it's not that hard what exactly
do you know is happening and coming out
meadows trey Gowdy what do we have I
believe we are days if not weeks away
from the most compelling evidence in the
biggest political scandal in American
history Hannity viewers have known from
the beginning that it was the dossier
funded by Democrats that really fueled
this investigation but Comey and Brennan
and clapper they didn't defend the
dossier because it was written by a
known liar as you pointed out in your
monologue so instead they pivoted and
said they had all these legitimate
concerns about George papadopolis here's
what we're gonna learn yeah we had heard
from an unverified foreign source that
Papadopoulos might have been talking to
some Russians so there was Western
intelligence sent to spy on Papadopoulos
and there's actually recording in a
transcript of that conversation and
there Papadopoulos denies any illegal
conspiracy between the Trump campaign
and Russia so they had evidence
presumably that was against Papadopoulos
and for him and what they'll never be
able to defend is that they never
presented that evidence to the FISA
Court we know that they were warned they
were warned by Bruce or August 2016 they
were warned by this woman Miss Kubelik
at the State Department ten days prior
to the signing of the first FISA
application now we know on this whole
new level you're describing then they're
withholding exculpatory information from
the court to spy on an opposition party
campaign absolutely this is what
attorney general Barr means when he
talks about them putting their thumb on
the scale the government has an
obligation before a secret court with no
defense attorneys the grace to present
all these exculpatory evidence that
they've provided all the Excalibur Tory
evidence here they only presented
evidence that would cast people
associated with the Trump campaign in a
bad light without their multiple
professions of innocence now Comey and
clapper and Brennan are all going to say
well Papadopoulos might have known he
was being surveilled when he said none
of this stuff was actually happening but
there's still no excuse for why that
didn't go before a court and I'm sure
Greg Jarrett can explain
all of the laws and rules that they
broke and what is that you host the show
gates I mean you know but I have a
friend of mine in studio and that's why
I was talking before go ahead
congressman Gates is absolutely correct
there's an extra duty that the FBI James
Comey and Sally eighths of the DOJ had
when they presented their warrant
application to spy on somebody if they
have expelled the Tauri evidence they
have to provide that not only that is
you've pointed out all of the
information has to be verified if they
discover later on that it's not verified
or they were wrong they have to
immediately notify the court that we got
it wrong you must now reconsider they
didn't do any of that that's a fraud on
the court and five other fellows it's
it's deep it is a premeditated sure
fraud it is lying by omission not
highlighting who paid for it right it's
not verified they will warn twice maybe
three times they withheld looks culpa
Tory evidence this is the highest level
to one impact an election and the
outcome right also the person that they
saved from clear indictment number two
this is then and not an opportunity that
they used to try and take down a duly
elected president it is rank corruption
it is using your law enforcement office
to target somebody for political reasons
and lying to a court in the process it's
abuse of power it's perjury it's a false
statement it's obstruction of justice so
all of those that pull this off limit or
that to Matt it's easy to invent a lie
it's even easier to spread a lie if
there's nobody there to challenge it and
this is an ex parte hearing in front of
the FISA Court nobody on the other side
to look out for Carter paid and Matt
Gaetz either Comey lied when he said oh
she told me to call it a matter or
Loretta Lynch slide one of them lied
under oath which one pick one well I
mean I have literally you've got mo
you've got multiple circumstances where
Comey was lying and obviously this is
why Comey is attacking our great
Attorney General Bill bar bill bar is
asking the right questions we're going
to
down to who committed these crimes and
my suspension of runs that it roots back
in the Obama White House and remember he
signed the said it was verified in
October told Trump oh it's unverified
but salacious lied there one of those
times right